and police in the United States have
been giving an update on the shooting at
Michigan State University they say the
gunman who killed three students before
turning the gun on himself is 43 year
old Anthony McRae officers are yet vote
to determine a motive we do have three
total deceased and five victims at the
hospital we can confirm that all three
deceased were MSU students
we can also confirm at this time that
all five of the injured victims at the
hospital were also MSU students we are
prepared to release the name of the
person who committed these homicides at
this time
we have previously confirmed that he was
43 years old is a male
his name is Anthony
last name is McRae